40 state of New Mexico versus Hannah
Gutierrez read Hardy State their name
uh your honor Kerry Morrissey and Jesus
we can't hear you
okay can you hear me now
Jason I can hear you
I can't hear you oh okay judge you're
the only one that can't hear me can you
um this is Dr Marlo's assistant let me
go see what's going on because I can
hear you guys too so one second okay
okay
all right do you want to see if we can
hear you oh do you want to see if we can
hear you
sure uh perfect perfect
uh Kerry Morrissey and Jason Lewis on
behalf of the state of New Mexico
good afternoon your honor Jason Bowles
and Todd bullion are here for Hannah
Gutierrez Reed
okay uh your honor we asked asked for a
status conference uh to have an
opportunity to get some guidance from
the court
uh in terms of the recent changes on the
case
uh having
dismissed the charges currently against
Mr Baldwin uh we want to get some
guidance from the court in terms of our
current time limits obviously the
preliminary hearing will now I don't
believe take two weeks
um and in addition to that myself and Mr
Bowles are on the same page in terms of
wanting to get as much time prior to a
preliminary hearing as we can to
complete the rest of the investigation
on all of these important issues that
have surfaced just within the last few
days
okay so sorry
uh your honor that is correct and uh I
don't know what the Court's uh calendar
looks like and what the court would
prefer to do but we were wanting to see
if we could get additional time I think
our current date is is through the end
of June I believe June 26th around that
time frame uh so we were just gonna see
if the court would have additional time
and I agree with Miss Morrissey that it
would would not be two weeks at this
point
so am I understanding that you want to
vacate this completely and move it to
another week is that the bottom line yes
sir that's the bottom line and depending
on on the Court's perspective I guess
this is one of the issues that that I
wanted some guidance on
um it does the court believe that it is
within the defendants right does the
defendant have a right to waive the 120
day time uh limits on a prelim or do you
think that the 120 days is hard and fast
and it must be completed within the 120
days that being the deadline of June
26th
well I think that he can wave it she can
wave it uh what do you I'm as long as
she puts it in writing and she's very
clear that that she can wave it I don't
see a problem with that
I'm sorry your honor
we would concur uh we thought we uh
would want to put that in writing before
the court and waive those time limits
but just wanted the Court's guidance on
that
and you said so are you even so the time
frame is June the deadline right now is
June 26 and you need more time than that
so what where were you thinking
Miss Marcy do you
my preference would be if I had at least
60 to 90 days
uh completing this investigation is
going to require uh probably the uh
issuance of subpoenas uh and some of
those subpoenas will be issued in order
to take witness statements prior to the
preliminary hearing so that's going to
take a little bit of time but obviously
uh whatever the court thinks is
appropriate in terms of your calendar is
what we're going to do
August is good yes
all right
faith I don't have um do I have a dock a
call I know I have one July 20th but do
I have one on um in August it's not
calendared yet
we do not okay perfect that's what I
thought okay so August is good
so
um
and I don't have trial dates in August
correct faith
um we have trial dates jury selection is
August 22nd and then trials August 23rd
through September 1st but that's the
only one what did you jury selection on
August 22nd is that what you said yes
and the trial is August 23rd through
September 1st okay so we're talking the
first two um weeks of August
so
um so you think it's going to take one
week or do you think it's going to go
into another week
because yeah if we do then we should
start the first like August 7th
because if it goes in I don't want it to
go into the the trial week
let's go ahead and start August 7th just
to be safe that we end up having enough
time
all right now that's a Monday do you
think that's going to be any you know
last minute motions that you might we
might need that Monday for
Thursday
I doubt it because I think that what
what we're going to do is uh set this up
the way that we had it previously set up
where we have emotions deadline built in
uh just because of the number of
witnesses that will be subpoenaed
may I inquire uh the court and Miss
Morrissey if this could possibly start
the 31st I don't know if you have that
time your honor I just looked we are on
a trail encounter August 7th which we I
think we're going later in that month uh
before judge Beachside
in a civil medical malpractice trial
are you do you mean the 31st of July or
August yes 31st of July
I can do that
I don't think so
no well so you wanted to go that week no
that's my that's another jury trial week
okay
we also have the 14th that we're not
trying a case in that week but I know
we're getting close to the this Court's
jury trial document
well we could start midweek when did you
have that uh matter
uh your honor it starts to Monday the
7th
and that's equivalent to a docket call
yes judge it's a trailing calendar trial
uh before you just need to be present
for that is that right I'm sorry yes sir
so why don't we start the ninth and that
way we can go into the 14th and then we
we have two more days that week in case
we go over
similar to what we were going to do yes
your honor
all right so we'll calendar August 9th
to August 16th knowing that um we also
may as time goes on see if we need the
17th 18th right yes yes okay and so
um faith will send an amended scheduling
order and then we will start
at 9 30 um
every day just to avoid the crowd at
eight o'clock when the employees come in
will that work for you all
yes your honor yes
and then um you all worked out on your
own a scheduling order and um when you
do a new scheduling order and
um submit it to me I'll sign it
yes Shannon we'll do that yes sure thank
you okay is there anything else on on
this matter that we need
not today I don't think so certainly not
on behalf of the state okay and now on
behalf of Miss Gutierrez
okay all right thank you Council
thank you all right bye-bye bye